disney used early cinema technology to
launch one of the most famous
entertainment companies in the world
marvel pulled off a similar trip
bringing comic books to life
and now super plastic's origin story
begins in the metaverse
imagine that you wanted to make an
entertainment company but your basic
position was
that the normal powers that be the big
studios and streaming services they're
big slow
not always the most risk-taking people
and you wanted to kind of do it your own
way
i had a lot of experience with kid robot
my previous company with these like just
giant studios paying us lots of money to
never actually make anything or to make
things so slowly or to ruin them along
the way and the idea was well what if we
made animated characters
that we loved gave them lives on social
media and used social media as our
primary entertainment platform and so
rather than posting videos on even
youtube or dealing with i don't know
television or amazon or whatever
we use instagram and tick
[Music]
[Applause]
tock have a universe of characters but
they talk back they cross in and out of
traditional media
and they're 3d animated and they're
human but they wear real fashion but
they're not human because they're like
half animal half beasts but they hang
out with real celebrities so it's just
this really weird mix-up between what's
real and what's not
inside a century-old warehouse in
burlington vermont super plastic's team
of designers writers and former
animators from pixar and dreamworks
create detailed backstories and
narratives surrounding these characters
the general rule is like sort of
truthfully how [ __ ] up can we be
before we're kicked off tick tock
that's the
again
actually
we go we walk right up to the edge and
see how far we can take it
since its seed round in 2018 the company
has raised 46 million dollars from a
mixed bag of backers google ventures
index ventures ashton kutcher justin
timberlake the chainsmokers and geraldo
it also received another four million
dollars in strategic investments from
amazon sony japan animoca and caring
we've been blessed with a combination of
good timing
around especially the web3 stuff that we
are in the middle of and also just with
sort of the rise of the metaverse when
christie's approached us about doing an
nft drop we were like okay great what
would let's just see what jake and
google want to do
so they broke into christie's
stole a bunch of art
accidentally blew christie's up which i
can't believe that christie's let us do
that and they escaped with the cops
chasing after them and and then they
decided with all the stuff all the
broken artwork that they put it back
together and that was the nft drop it
was reconstructed pieces of the stuff
that they stole so some of it's
metaverse stuff somebody's lifestyle
some of the product stuff it's all of it
together
it's a fun part is that you know we get
to craft that